okay your gift Kara you know the bit I
said about gravity doing the first bid
yeah that's wrong you're just gonna have
to muscle it out most of the way oh no
hopefully I'll get across before I get
scared that's what I'm hoping for
so speed is my key which probably isn't
very clever but whatever good tell you
what this is gonna be a workout for her
oh my god oh god I'm scared
oh this is gonna be so long so much
friction with the ripe and the karabiner
over it the each couple of feeds is like
a pull-up oh oh
push it back all of the way and already
cheese grinding to a halt
sorry you can do this push that device
as far forward as you can there you go
you need both hands great job keep
pushing you do it guys
oh come on
go girl doing so well just inch it out
muscle it out so close so close keep
coming okay go on you're busted another
five foot you're there I'm so good
[Music]
you want me
here we go here we go oh my god that was
really hard sweat speed is usually my
go-to it was a bad idea cuz after I got
halfway just tore me up my core my arms
yeah that last bit was really hardcore
my my stomach is shaking huh good it's
good never give up never give up never
go third yeah so that was definitely
harder work than I anticipated that our
car muscled it out she got great natural
physicality of strength the motorpool he
kind of that never give our spirit and
out here that is king
[Music]